if your parents are financially helping
you you need to change your tone intent
or how you interact with your parents
listen I don't think there's anything
bad about getting support from your
parents what I'm trying to keep you all
away from is entitlement because that
destroys the soul you know why so many
people are unhappy they expect everyone
to do everything for them they expect
the government to do it for them their
parents to do it for them their company
to do it for them their boss to do it
for them their boyfriend to do
appointment their girlfriend like get
off that the quickest way I can promise
to make all of you happy is to stand on
your own two feet and be accountable and
expect from yourself you will get so
much happier I promise